GUEST SPEAKER: Good morning.
Thank you for
inviting me here today
to speak to you about
the liquefied natural gas
facility in Boston Harbor.
Based on my experience as
director of the Boston Harbor
Associates, I believe that
the risks of this LNG facility
are too high and that
a new risk assessment
is needed to properly
evaluate these risks.
This morning I'd
like to tell you
about the problems with
the current risk assessment
and then provide my
recommendations for a new risk
assessment going forward.
As you know LNG has a very--
it comes with the
possibility of a gas
leak, which could lead to a
fire and a large explosion.
Although this happening
is fairly unlikely,
the severity of the damages that
would happen if it did occur
would be extremely large.
And risks are
greater when LNG is
transported through the water.
If a spill occurs in water,
it would spread more quickly
and be more
difficult to contain.
So we can expect that if a spill
did happen in Boston Harbor,
it would be very
difficult to manage.
It would quickly spread
to the Harbor Islands
and also around the city, and
could cause a large explosion
that would not only have
major damage on infrastructure
and property, but
also could cause
a major loss of human life.
I know that you're all
well aware of these risks,
but you probably are assuming
that the risk assessment that
was done when the
facility was built--
several decades ago-- accurately
takes into account these risks.
However, I believe that
there are major problems
with that risk assessment.
First of all, the
risk assessment
assumes that everything
possible to manage these risks
is being done.
It doesn't leave any possibility
for human error or negligence,
or any mistakes happening.
However, there's very
little evaluation
to ensure that all of
these safety measures
are being taken
100% of the time.
There's site visits by
the regulatory agency
only several times
a year, and these
are announced ahead of time.
So they don't accurately reflect
whether the safety measures are
being taken day in and day out.
We know that human
error can lead
to major industrial accidents.
Just look at the case of
Three Mile Island, where
the accident was made worse
by inadequate training
and the plant operators failing
to respond to the problem
as it was unfolding and
making the problem worse.
So given that we know that
human error and negligence can
lead to major accident, I'd
like to propose a new risk
assessment that takes
these into account.
My recommendation for
a new risk assessment
follows a 2-step process, in
which the estimation of risk
is separate from the
decision making process.
So in the first step,
the government--
all of your
respective agencies--
with input from
the public, would
determine what level of risk
it is willing to accept.
For example, is it willing to
accept some water pollution
permanently?
What about property damage?
What about loss of life?
What level of risk can you,
as a society, tolerate?
It's very important that
you involve the public
in determining the level of risk
that you're willing to accept.
Not only will this help them
feel like they have ownership
in the decision that
effects their home,
but it will also help them think
about the likelihood of risk
and whether this
technology is appropriate.
While I'm sure that they're
not necessarily scared
about the risks, but rather
that they understand what
might happen with
this technology.
So after you've determined
what level of risk
you, as a society,
are willing to accept,
I would recommend that you
hire a group of scientists
to conduct the risk
assessment itself,
and to figure out both
the harms from a gas
leak that are possible and the
likelihood of this occurring.
In addition, it's
really important
that as part of this
risk assessment,
you assume that some degree
of human error will occur
and that safety measures will
not be followed all the time.
The scientists can estimate this
based on accidents at other LNG
facilities around the world,
and what led to these accidents,
and whether or not
safety measures were
being followed there.
After the risk
assessment is completed,
the government can
look at the results
and decide whether it meets the
previously set determination
of risk that the society
is willing to accept.
And if it does, to go forward
and keep the facility open,
and if not, close the facility.
One important thing
to note is that if you
do decide to keep
the facility open,
it's very important that
there is a mechanism in place
for regular monitoring
of safety at the plant,
and to ensure that
all of the safety
measures that were assumed
and the risk assessment are
actually being followed.
Finally, it's very important
to compare the alternatives.
LNG, natural gas, is a
major source of energy,
especially for heating,
in the Boston area.
And if it's found too risky, we
need to replace this facility
with another source of energy.
So whether that comes
from natural gas
through pipelines,
or oil heating,
or some kind of
renewable energy,
all of these energy sources
have some kind of risk.
So it's important to measure
the risks of those as well,
and make sure that we're
not replacing the LNG
with something even riskier.
So to conclude, I believe
that the risks of this LNG
facility in Boston
Harbor are very high,
and that the current risk
assessment is inadequate.
I hope you'll follow my
recommendations for a new risk
assessment that better
takes into account both
the dangers of this technology
and the level of risk
that society is
willing to accept.
Thank you.